Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Luminosa, brillante, y alegre.
Es una de las melodías más familiares de
todas las de principios del siglo XVIII.
Se ha ejecutado en innumerables
películas y anuncios de televisión,
pero ¿qué es y por qué
suena de esa manera?
Es la apertura de la "Primavera"
de "Las cuatro estaciones",
del compositor italiano Antonio Vivaldi.
"Las cuatro estaciones" son famosas en
parte porque son una delicia para el oído.
Sin embargo, aún más notable
es el hecho de que tienen
historias que contar.
En el momento de su publicación
en Ámsterdam en 1725,
fueron acompañados por poemas
que describen exactamente
las características de la estación
que Vivaldi pretende captar
en términos musicales.
En dar contenido específico
a la música instrumental,
Vivaldi fue generaciones
por delante de su tiempo.
Si uno lee los poemas de
forma simultánea a escuchar la música,
puede encontrar las escenas poéticas
sincronizadas perfectamente
con la imaginería musical.
Dice que los pájaros dan la bienvenida
a la primavera con una canción feliz,
y aquí están haciendo exactamente eso.
Pronto, sin embargo,
una estalla una tormenta.
No solo hay truenos
y relámpagos musicales,
también hay más pájaros,
mojados, asustados e infelices.
En "Verano", la tórtola canta
su nombre "tortorella" en italiano,
antes de que una tormenta de granizo
aplane los campos.
El "Otoño" trae cazadores deseosos de
salir corriendo en busca de sus presas.
El concierto de "Invierno" comienza
con castañeteo de dientes por el frío
antes de que uno
se refugie cerca de la chimenea.
Luego es hora
de volver a la tormenta
donde habrá caídas
y resbalones en el hielo.
En estas primeras semanas de invierno,
el viejo año está llegando a su fin,
y lo mismo ocurre con la exploración
musical del Vivaldi de las estaciones.
No fue hasta principios del siglo XIX
que un programa musical tan expresivo,
como era conocido,
se popularizó.
Para entonces, conjuntos más grandes
y variados eran la regla
con instrumentos de viento, metales y
percusión para ayudar a la historia.
Pero Vivaldi lo logró con solo un violín,
cuerdas y un clavicordio.
A diferencia de su contemporáneo Bach,
Vivaldi no tenía mucho interés
en fugas complicadas.
Prefería ofrecer entretenimiento
de fácil acceso a sus oyentes
con melodías que aparecen
de nuevo más tarde en la pieza
para recordarnos dónde hemos estado.
El primer movimiento de la "Primavera"
inicia con un tema para la primavera
y termina con el mismo ligeramente variado
de cuando fue escuchado por última vez.
Fue una forma inspirada
de atraer a los oyentes,
y Vivaldi,
considerado uno de los violinistas más
electrizantes de inicios del siglo XVIII,
entendió el valor de atraer audiencias.
En dichos conciertos podría figurar
él mismo como el violinista estrella.
Otros presentan a las
jóvenes músicas de la Piedad,
una escuela femenina de Venecia,
donde Vivaldi fue Director de Música.
La mayoría de las estudiantes
eran huérfanas.
La enseñanza musical buscaba no solo
darles habilidades sociales para señoritas
sino también una posible carrera
para aquellas que pudieran
lograr un buen matrimonio.
Incluso en tiempos del compositor,
la música de Vivaldi
sirvió como diversión a todos,
no solo a los ricos aristócratas.
300 años más tarde,
es un enfoque que todavía funciona,
y la música de Vivaldi aún suena
como caballos al trote en movimiento.